ein neuerlicher giftgas einsatz in
syrien hat zu luftschlägen usa und
verbündete geführt die konfrontation
zwischen israel und iran nimmt immer
konkretere formen an und die türkei hat
eine neuerliche offensive innovationen
gestattet es scheint dass der konflikt
der krieg in syrien in eine
entscheidende phase tritt heute in
vechta kompakt syrien kriegsende in
sicht
[Musik]
das erste halbe jahr 2018 ist eine der
blutigsten phasen im syrischen
bürgerkrieg beinahe täglich werden 100
personen getötet und 8000 vertrieben
das kann infolge von weiteren offensiven
des regimes oder auch evakuierungs
abkommen noch steigen
vier entwicklungen sind maßgeblich dafür
verantwortlich
hier ist erstens zu erwähnen dass das
regime seine angriffe wieder in den
westteil des landes verlagert hat ging
es 2017 auch darum den islamischen staat
im osten zu bekämpfen und großteils zu
besiegen ist es in der phase 2018 jetzt
darum gegangen die verbliebenen
rebellengebiete anzugreifen
das wurde durchgeführt mit massiven
luftschlägen mit heftigen bodenoffensive
und hat dazu geführt dass viele
gefangene in diesen gebieten entweder
einem evakuierungs abkommen zugestimmt
haben oder sich ergeben haben
die zweite entwicklung war der türkische
vorstoß zur eroberung des kurdischen
kantons april binnen weniger monate
wurde das gebiet eingenommen und
präsident erdogan hat angedroht weiter
an den euphrat vorzustoßen sollte es zu
keiner politischen einigung mit den usa
über die autonomie der kurden kommen
eine dritte entwicklung entstand durch
den neuerlichen einsatz von giftgas in
der umgebung von damaskus
die usa und viele westliche staaten
haben ersatz dafür verantwortlich
gemacht diese hat von einer aktion der
rebellen gesprochen
letztlich führte es dazu dass die usa
gemeinsam mit großbritannien und
frankreich raketenbeschüsse von
chemiewaffen produktionsstätten und
lagerorten durchgeführt haben
sie haben allerdings betont dass es sich
dabei nicht um eine einmischung in den
bürgerkrieg handle sondern einen
vergeltungsschlag und auch einen
vorbeugung schlag damit zukünftig
einsätze von chemiewaffen unterbleiben
die vierte entwicklung besteht in der
zunehmenden konfrontation zwischen iran
und israel
der abschluss einer drohne der beschuss
des kulant massive luftschläge auf
vermutete pro-iranische stellungen in
syrien zeigen
unglaublich hohes konfliktpotenzial hier
besteht israel liegt daran keine pro
iranischen kräfte an seiner grenze
stationiert zu haben
diese entwicklungen kommen in der
gebiets kontrolle sehr gut zum ausdruck
stand mai 2018 regime 60 prozent wurden
mit us-unterstützung 25% islamischer
staat er wüssten gebiet 3 prozent
vermutlich die rebellen im norden und im
süden des landes an die vier prozent die
usa gemeinsam mit lokalen verbündeten 2
prozent das ist das grenzgebiet zwischen
irak jordanien und syrien und die türkei
mit ihren verbündeten auch annähernd 2
prozent
wie könnte es daher weiter gehen welche
entwicklungen zeichnen sich ab der
bürgerkrieg in syrien ist etwas achte
jahr getreten
es scheint aber mittlerweile um die
nachkriegsordnung zu gehen und die
könnte sich 2018 entscheiden
daher werden militärische offensiven
keine großen veränderungen mehr
herbeiführen können abgesehen dass man
das letzte territorium vom islamischen
staat einnimmt
die position von azad ist gefestigt er
wird eine wesentliche rolle spielen und
russland ist der zentrale akteure auch
wenn es um verhandlungen um eine
nachkriegsordnung geht auch die türkei
und der iran werden am verhandlungstisch
sitzen und maßgeblich mitbestimmen der
rolle der usa ist hingegen fraglich ist
zeichnet sie gab dass sie ihre aufgabe
den schutz der kunden an andere
überträgt frankreich arabische staaten
wurden hier schon genannt und damit auch
keine konfrontation mit dem nato partner
türkei aus dem weg geht der
friedensprozess liegt derzeit auf eis er
ist gelähmt
allerdings könnte sich nach einnahme der
letzten rebellengebiete oder abkommen
über abzüge und waffenstillstand eine
neue situation ergeben so dass man hier
tatsächlich ende 2018 die
voraussetzungen geschaffen hat um
ernsthaft friedensgespräche führen zu
können